Graphs have some additional
properties that make them useful for
modeling various types of data.
Edges can have a direction, meaning
the relationship between two nodes only
applies one way and not the other.
Directed graph is the term for
a graph where the edges
have a sense of direction.
For example, if you're using a graph
to represent travel plans, a directed
edge can be used to show which city
you start in and which you travel to.
Often one node will be the start and
the other the end of the relationship or
action taking place.
You might describe the edge of
a graph as the first node, a verb,
the word to, and the other node.
Here, it's, From SF, travel to Tokyo.
If you make a round trip and travel
through the same two cities going in
opposite directions, you might have
two edges between the same two nodes,
one representing each
direction you travel in.
An undirected graph has edges
with no sense of direction.
For example, if you have a graph of
people and edges are drawn between two
people who have met before,
directed edges might be unnecessary.
I previously mentioned that graphs
can have cycles but trees can't.
A cycle happens in a graph when
you can start at one node and
follow edges all the way
back to that node.
00:01:26,800 --> 00:01:26,620
Cycles in
graphs can be really dangerous
when you're describing algorithms.
You might write some code to travel
through the nodes in your graph.
But if you have a cycle, you might just
go through the same sequence again and
again and again in an infinite loop.
You often need to make sure the graph
you're taking in as input is acyclic,
meaning it has no cycles.
One type that shows up often is a dag,
or directed, acyclic graph.
It's really just what it sounds like,
a directed graph with no cycles.